for reaction we're joined by Congressman
Steve King of Iowa member of an
immigration and border security
subcommittee in Congress it's good to
see you but this is disturbing I mean
this this is just wild what's happening
you have these lawyers including this
guy who's one of the lead lead lawyers
in this effort
Alex mincing he's a project coordinator
for Pueblo sinfronteras which is
organizing this effort to help these you
know help the caravans and the concern
congressman is that we have American
lawyers and other nongovernmental
organizations almost working
hand-in-glove de facto with media
outlets to push Mexico Mexican election
coming up in a few months
put the political pressure pressure on
Mexico and as I said keep it all going
so they make their way up to Tijuana and
then what watching this caravan make its
way towards the United States and divert
towards Tijuana and seeing them away
they're facilitating this with the media
and with the immigration attorneys at
which the immigration attorney
organization has at least 15,000 members
in the United States of that
organization
there's federal statutes that prohibit
and create a felony for contributing and
eating and embedding illegal immigration
they'd better have their laws right if
they're going to go to a foreign country
and help facilitate an unarmed invasion
into the United States but we are weak
on our Asylum laws and that Asylum law
was passed by a voice in the middle of
the night after everybody left for the
airport for Christmas vacation a few
years ago several years I don't have the
exact year but I looked it up when I
read the text of that and they were
ready to gavel out and everybody headed
to the airport and it was set up to be
this was back during the Pelosi era when
she was in the speaker and when harry
reems my people don't understand you
claim asylum when you say you have a
credible fear of persecution for a
variety of reasons I mean it's really
lacks you can it's for race religion
nationality membership in a particular
social group I don't even know what that
means and political opinion god some of
us feel persecuted for having a
political opinion here but for that
those grounds you can claim asylum and
overwhelmingly the immigration judges
have granted asylum or
allowed people to be released then they
never come back for their hearing or
deportation proceedings nobody's trained
them what to say so when they arrive
workshops they're doing these workshops
with these migrants I said I stood up on
the cliff outside aroma Texas a few
years ago and watch them watch them
inflate the raft bring a pregnant lady
across with two coyotes escorting a
pregnant lady they brought it up to the
shore and the grass helped her out
handed her two little ditty bags of her
possessions and she stood and patiently
waited for the Border Patrol to come
along to claim credible fear
why haven't Republicans in Congress done
anything really to change this law I
know you've been a staunch advocate of
strengthening our immigration laws
non-contiguous countries meaning other
than Mexico Guatemala Honduras Salvador
of Central America and beyond if they
show up at our border and they throw
themselves at a Border Patrol agent
Meredith across the border just show up
they can get an asylum in the United
States very easily or at least be
released into the United States easily
we must have a new law that says you can
be expeditiously and immediately removed
back to your country like you you are if
you're a Mexican Mexicans don't have
that ability only other than Mexicans
have that ability to be released back
into the United States that's that's
nuts and we talked about this one judge
in you know in DC who's just part of the
judicial tyranny now well just changing
the language for asylum the credible
fair language we went down and did a
tour of the border last October with
chairman Bob Goodlatte and others we
went through with the court system we
saw a lot of what was going on but that
simple change is written into the Davis
Oliver Act that's got a lot of
enforcement provisions in it this act
this act is it's looking for a way to
come to the floor and debate Paul Ryan
he's not gonna bring it to the floor
yeah it seemed to me that the votes were
a little short because it's tied up in
some of the Republicans insist on daca
amnesty is part of it you cannot just do
something that protects the American
people that protects our sovereignty our
borders our health our our national
security you can't just do that for the
American people without a big giveaway
to illegal immigrants
correct and that's people watching this
like they just want to throw something
on top of this I do and I'm posting the
show the president whom I support had
promised that he was going to end akka
but he served up doc doc don't talk
about that drove me crazy to 13000 up
say we shouldn't make a deal between a
rule of law and amnesty a completely 186
thirteen thousand 186 UAMS know the
acronym unaccompanied minors under 17
have already been released this year in
fiscal year 2018 and Laura I could
guarantee you that they were driven to
bus two or flown to all 50 states the
records show the real answers they go to
sponsors and they may go to an address
in Las Vegas who knows it could be a
coyote house it could be a drug
smuggling Valentinus we thought the
ms-13 and I was in Arizona when we
collared an ms-13 and when they busted
him for a pickup load of marijuana 240
pounds he had a yadus tattoo on his arm
13 I saw it with my eyes and I unloaded
that marijuana 240 pounds of it it is a
stunning thing when you put your eyes on
it you'll walk into those warehouses
you'll go into those jails about 81
percent mailed by the data I'm looking
at and some of those youth have a little
gray in their beard Laura oh I get it so
they might not be seventeen congressman
we got to get something done thank you
so much for your thank you see and work
on this